you mentioned paying respects to the uh
Legacy of ebj Eddie Bernice Johnson and
um remembering Palestinian child
prisoners can you
explain so congresswoman Eddie Bernice
Johnson was one of the few co-sponsors
of a bill that has been on the floor of
Congress for years uh initially
sponsored by congresswoman Betty
McCullum to penalize Israel for its
Detention of child prisoners thousands
of children arbitrarily detained put in
military courts solitary confinement and
yes sexual violence that's been
documented by human rights organizations
against
them and there have been no
repercussions so I want you to think
about this you know just the thought of
conditioning a to Israel you know so
that it doesn't indiscriminately bomb
entire populations
has not been able to find any home in
mainstream American
politics for
years just trying to stop Israel from
picking up children and throwing them
into military prisons where they
disappear for decades at times has not
found any thrust in mainstream American
politics whereas any resolution that is
pro-israel will make it past both
Chambers relatively quickly
when people talk about Israeli
hostages and then talk about Palestinian
prisoners there's already a problem with
that
framing first of all all 2.2 million
people in Gaza are hostages every
Palestinian that lives under occupation
is a hostage but all of those prisoners
that have been picked up women children
innocent people with absolutely no
process of making sure that they're
treated right
or given uh Fair trials or even given a
communication line with their families
or with any government to help them is
absolutely criminal all of those
prisoners are also
hostages and when you when you when you
are already propose this idea that there
are Israeli hostages and Palestinian
prisoners you're already implying that
one group is
complicit in their own devastation
whereas another group has had
Devastation visited upon them entirely
out of their own doing and so it's
important for people to learn about
children prisoners who are indeed
hostages to an apartheid
system and even what happened during
that 4-day
truce which all of us hoped would be
extended and become permanent where 150
Palestinian prisoners were released
Israel just went and picked up another
135 in the West Bank and threw them in
prisons that's what I mean when I say
you're not addressing the root of the
problem the root of the problem is the
occupation the root of the problem is
the apartheid the root of the problem is
the desperation that then drives the
creation of all sorts of
circumstances that will only further
lead to the devastation of everyone
right if you don't solve that problem
and at the root of that problem is the
dehumanization of the pal Ian because no
one is Raising alarms for those
Palestinian hostages in Israeli military
prisons no one's putting up their
pictures and no one's talking about who
they are and their human stories and the
violence that's been wreaked against
them at every level so if you don't
solve not just the root of occupation
but also the dehumanization that drives
the occupation which is unfortunately so
pervasive right now in the discourse
then you're going to continue to have
this Gap and how the world sees the
plight of the Palestinians and how
unfortunately the American public uh
sees the problem of the
Palestinians and to you big peace
agreements like uh of the like of
Abraham Accords should include Palestine
Abraham Accords is nothing but an
agreement in which you slap the name of
Abraham on arms deals in exchange for
countries being able to undertake their
own Unholy Pursuits they use one of the
holiest names in history and continue to
erase the main victims of this atrocity
and so the Abraham Accords are an insult
to humanity an insult to the
Palestinians and an insult to the name
of
Abraham but do you think something like
that agreements of that nature of that
scale could be made that include
Palestinian people and that would
actually have make progress if they're
honest to the plight of the Palestinians
if they are honest to the roots of the
problem absolutely look again peace is
sought but peace cannot be used to
silence the entire peace
process has you know been been hung over
the Palestinians all of these years
while settlements continue to expand and
their situation only continued to get
worse
is Israel really going to remove the
700,000
800,000 settlers right and uh suddenly
changes tune on a two-state solution
Benjamin Netanyahu is saying right now
and he's speaking to unfortunately what
is clearly a majority of the Israeli
public that there will never be a
Palestinian state so these peace talks
cannot be used to suffocate all of the
work of justice and bringing Israel to
accountability the world has to act when
they see apartheid the world has to act
when they see occupation if the world
fails to bring Israel to a place of
accountability then a few countries that
have their own agendas cannot put forth
anything meaningful for the victims of
Israel being the Palestinian
people
that